[Music]  Kim Kardashian is back in the Big Apple  making another bold statement with her  style my advice would be go for it the  36 year old reality star may be sporting  camo cut-offs but she sure isn't  blending in here's Kim k going braless  in a sheer black bodysuit camo shorts  and silver heels while out and about in  NYC with her sister Kendall Jenner on  Tuesday you kind of try and go for  what's up whatever's the most unique and  different meanwhile Kendall had her  supermodel legs on display wearing an  off-the-shoulder floral mini dress and  knee-high boots to walk around Manhattan  Soho neighborhood well it's clear both  stars are comfortable in their own skin  in these i popping on some bowls i want  to wear things that make me feel good  about myself  [Music]